hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the Norwegian chess
League it's Magnus Carlsen versus uh
John Ludwig Hammer we already checked
out the first game Magnus played and
this is now his second one and the third
one will be against David Howell which
should be his last game as a reigning
world classical Champion now uh the
Magnus and young Ludwig Hammer know each
other very well they uh I think they're
even good friends and uh he's been a
magnus's second in His World Church
championship match against in 2013. so
uh they know each other very well on end
of the board and it's not easy to
prepare for uh for such a game
especially in classical chess so let's
see uh what Magnus brings to the board
he plays Knight to F3 the reti opening
with Ponte D5 E3 Knight to F6 and now c4
challenging the D5 Pawn E6 Knights the
C3 with Pawn to C5 and now Pawn to D for
transposing into the uh into the semi
tarash the captors and C4 it's uh it's
not a an extremely rare continuation but
usually people will just play Knight to
C6 here here a hammer goes for D
captures on C4 Bishop captures with
Ponte A6 and now Pawn to A4 by Magnus
inviting C characters on D4 and uh there
are a few uh games that reach this
position where B5 was played but here we
do have C captures on D4 and it is not
as of move seven that we have a
completely new game at Magnus recaptures
with Bishop to D6 and now Queen to E2 we
have Queen to C7 uh preventing uh Magnus
from castling and the bishop to G5 now
and now Bishop to D7 uh it's very
interesting you could capture an H2 it
it is possible to capture I mean you
will lose the game but it's very
interesting why it's impossible to
capture uh I will just show it um the
problem is Knight to F3 and the bishop
has nowhere to go but if you go back to
D6 then just D5 it loses you the piece
uh but it's interesting what happens if
touch of the E5 Knight captures Queen
captures F4 Queen goes back with Pawn to
E5 challenges the Knight and now once
the Knight moves you just capture Bishop
captures e captures Knight captures
attacks the queen queen to A5 check now
connects with the Knight on D5 and now
The Sensational Pawn to B4 now look at
this you have to capture the queen and
now Rook D1 and black resigns you either
move the queen or and uh you gotta move
the queen and then Rook to the 80s
Checkmate or you capture and then uh
okay black is down a queen black has a
rook and Knight for a queen but it's not
much much of a compensation so that's
why you do not capture on H2 in case you
were wondering with Bishop to D7 Knight
to F3 now comes Knight to C6 and the
bishop to B3 we have Knight to G4 now
putting a lot of pressure on magnus's
King side just Rook to D1 by Magnus with
Knight G to E5 now offering some trades
here and the bishop to H4 getting ready
to shift the bishop over to this
diagonal we have Knight captures Queen
captures and now Knight to A5 uh hammer
uh looking to trade as many pieces as
possible here Bishop to G3 Bishop
captures eight captures and now Knight
captures on B3 with a capture some B3
now doubling up magn both magnus's
b-pawn and the g pawn and here uh uh
hammer castles and now you you're
probably thinking okay how is Magnus uh
uh gonna exploit exploit this will he uh
do some sort of a weird Rook doubling
will he play King of King G1 maybe
sacrifice the E5 Pawn maybe shift The
Rook over to help out with the attack
maybe clear the E4 Square for the Knight
then maybe Knight comes into the attack
uh none of that Magnum just plays Queen
to F4 and he offers a queen trade and
okay Queen captures on F4 G captures an
F4 uh and now Bishop to C6 putting
pressure on D for Pawn we have Pawn to
F3 and pawn to F5 now we have Pawn to E5
and now Rook 8 to d8 offering a rook
trade King to E2 and here Hammer trait
with Rook captures Rook captures and now
just King to F7 the king now wants to
come to E7 and then the Rook can claim
the open D file or maybe the open C file
all depends on what the Magnus plays
King E3 with King t7 Knight to E2 now
also bring up the the C file for The
Rook if if Rook to the display so Magnus
doesn't trade everything right away the
chapter D5 goes after the pawn and now
just Knights the D4 and usually when you
will have a bishop against the knight uh
on a full board with pawns on both sides
of the board a bishop should be a little
bit stronger than a knight but here both
kings are nicely centralized the Rooks
are still in the game so Bishop is not
that much better than a knight in this
situation plus the Knight is positioned
brilliantly it's on a dark Square so the
bishop cannot attack it and it's very
unlikely that The Rook will capture it
at any point so here we have G6 Rook the
H1 forcing uh hammer to figure out what
to do with the H7 Pawn Rook to F7 and
now Pawn to B for getting rid of the
weakness on B3 and also maybe with some
ideas of Pawn to B5 with King to d8
Shifting the king over to the queen side
and now Pawn to B5 we have King to C7
and Rook the C1 with check King the B6
and now B captures an A6 also you could
consider something like Rook to see it
but Magnus has a different idea
characters captures Rook 8 to C8 now and
pawn to A5 with King to D3 and now Rook
to G7 uh sorry uh Rook to G7 just
wasting a move here uh Rook to d8 now
Magnus uh wants to play Rook to D6 with
check and then gobble up the E6 Pawn
with the Knight and here a hammer should
just play Rook to E7 he should keep this
Pawn defended it's nicely defended
everything else is nicely defended the
king defends the A5 Pawn uh this uh this
will be possible to hold however after
this Rook to d8 move he played King to
C5 and well it's a it's a nice move it
does allow Magnus one particular move
that wins the game so feel free to pause
the video and win this game for Magnus
while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on being a true
Master of the end game and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Rook the uh sorry
B8 cutting of the king from the from the
beep file and also threatening Rook the
B5 Checkmate and the only way to stop
this is to block
um uh the the The Rook via the B7 Square
you could play Bishop to B7 but then you
also blunder the E6 Pawn so here Rook
the B7 is forced and now Magnus just
plays Knight captures on E6 with check
of course if you capture then you lose
the Rook so King to B4 and now he trades
Rooks Rook captures Bishop captures and
King to D4 and now if you count to the
material Magnus is up upon and he does
have the past E Pawn and now it's only a
matter of moving the Knight and
advancing this Pawn to Victory so Bishop
to C6 uh hammer has some idea see he
might be able to stop the pawn even even
uh if he has to give up the bishop for
the pawn he could still maybe capture
the beep on and then maybe start
advancing his a pawn to Victory or maybe
to a draw Knights the C5 by Magnus with
Pawn to H5 and now Pawn to B3 not even
allowing Ponte A4 we have Ponte H4 and
now Pawn to E6 by Magnus with Bishop to
A8 now
um uh the idea is uh like I said if Pawn
37 and Bishop C6 guards the E8 square
and now if you uh persist for example
Knight B7 of course you're not gonna
capture you need to keep an eye on that
square then uh a king B5 and now if
Knight to D6 would check you're going to
play King to B4 and now it seems like
okay but you can just you know win the
bishop uh it's not gonna be that great
uh King will capture on B3 and now how
are you stopping this Pawn sure you can
you can bring the Knight into the game
let's say Knight to C4 but now King
comes to C2 now the king starts um uh
going to the king side to gobble up
these Pawn so it would be very hard to
um uh you know restrain all of these
pawns uh so that's why after Bishop j8
Magnus just goes for 9 the D3 check King
captures on B3 and Knight to E5 and he
was now in this position and move 44
that yonoodwickham resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here so
Magnus wins as his second game in a row
in the Norwegian chess league and there
is uh only one that remains it is
tomorrow's game against David Howell and
that will be his last game as a reigning
world classical uh classical Champion
his last classical game uh so here at
the Knight is guarding the C6 square and
there is no way for the bishop to stop
promotion E7 E8 is coming next and it
doesn't really matter what you play if
you start the dancing the pawn just Pawn
to E7 and that's pretty much it this uh
the the pawn is too slow you're just not
in time to do anything if you want A3
you bring a Queen into the game that's
it uh so yeah uh that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it very nicely done by
by Magnus uh uh it was it was a fairly
equal position but this King to C5 move
just allowed Magnus this um uh this uh
you know uh uh winning idea but even if
you don't play King to C5 it's not easy
to to find moves here like other than
Rook D7 which is a very passive idea and
maybe maybe a hammer just wanted to also
keep winning chances alive and then he
played an active move uh but yeah like I
said uh that's what happened hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Chris
Foster
funky monk Revolution reptiles YouTube
and the second travel and tour safaris
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day